Aus meiner Sicht, aber auch
jener des Verwaltungsrates,
war dieser Auftrag zur Überwachung
falsch und unangemessen,
auch wenn sie subjektiv
zum Schutz der Interessen
der Gesellschaft angeordnet wurde.
Die getroffene Massnahme
war nicht verhältnismässig
und entspricht nicht
den Kriterien und Massstäben,
die wir an unsere Arbeit legen.
Ein Überwachungsskandal erschüttert
den Schweizer Finanzplatz.
Im Zentrum dieses Skandals:
die Credit Suisse.
Das ist nicht ein personelles
Problem - es ist viel grundlegender.
Der Reputationsschaden ist gross.
Das ist ein Krimi, ein Le Carre -
bester Thriller am Paradeplatz.
Diese Geschichte
beginnt Mitte September 2019.
Ein internationaler Topbanker ist
in der Zürcher Innenstadt unterwegs.
Er wird observiert.
Es sind Szenen
wie in einem Agentenfilm,
die sich
rund um den Paradeplatz abspielen.
Das ist der Verfolgte: Iqbal Khan,
vormaliger Chef der
internationalen Vermögensverwaltung
bei der Credit Suisse.
Er will die CS verlassen
und bei der UBS einsteigen.
Bei Rene Fitzi hat Iqbal Khan
eine Lehre als Treuhänder gemacht.
Sie stehen bis heute
in regelmässigem Kontakt.
Zuletzt nach den Ereignissen
Mitte September 2019.
Ich habe mit ihm darüber gesprochen.
Er brachte seinen Sohn
zum Fussballplatz.
Dann fuhr er mit seiner Frau
in die Stadt zum Essen.
Auf der ganzen Strecke
sah er im Spiegel einen Mietwagen,
der immer stark aufschloss.
Da wusste er: "Ich werde verfolgt."
Aber er hatte keine Ahnung,
worum es geht.
Khan fühlt sich offenbar
schon länger verfolgt.
Jemand ist hinter ihm her.
Khan weiss, er wird beobachtet.
Es ängstigte ihn brutal.
Ebenso seine Familie.
Seine Frau wurde ...
... immer observiert.
Es schlichen immer Leute ums Haus
und verfolgten sie auch.
Es war ganz, ganz schlimm.
Sie hatten echt Angst.
Mitte September 2019 eskaliert die
Situation in der Zürcher Innenstadt.
Khan beginnt,
seine Verfolger zu fotografieren.
In der Nähe des Paradeplatzes,
beim Restaurant Metropol,
kommt es zur Konfrontation.
Er stieg aus und machte ein Foto,
um die Nummer zu haben.
Da gingen sie
ziemlich bösartig auf ihn los.
Das waren nicht einfach Detektive,
sondern Bodybuilder
mit Tätowierungen -
richtige Schlägertypen.
Da hatte er logischerweise Angst.
Klar, das ist nicht toll.
Khan erstattet Anzeige.
Die Verfolger
werden kurz darauf verhaftet
und geben preis,
wer sie angeheuert hat:
Khans früherer Arbeitgeber,
die Credit Suisse.
Die Bank wollte offenbar wissen,
ob Khan versuchte, Mitarbeiter
und Kunden zur UBS mitzunehmen.
Der Skandal ist perfekt -
und wird bald öffentlich.
Denn der investigative Journalist
Lukas Hässig erfährt davon
und schreibt darüber.
Hässig hat beste Kontakte
in die Bankenwelt
und deckt immer wieder Brisantes auf.
Auf die Frage, ob ihn das Verhalten
der Credit Suisse erstaune, sagt er:
Was man wusste: Im Banking
wird sehr genau hingeschaut,
wenn jemand
von Bank X zu Bank Y wechselt.
Was tut er?
Welche Leute trifft er?
Was verspricht er ihnen?
Überschreitet er eine Grenze?
Wir hatten insbesondere bei der CS
zwei, drei Fälle,
in denen hohe Manager, als sie
in der Transferperiode waren -
wenn sie schon draussen sind,
aber noch vom alten Arbeitgeber
bezahlt werden
und nichts gegen dessen Interessen
machen dürfen -
Daten ausdruckten, privat mailten,
begannen,
bestehende Kunden zu treffen
mit Blick auf die neue Anstellung
bei einer anderen Bank.
Dann konnten sie
den Wechsel nicht vollziehen,
da ging die CS giftig rein.
Wir dachten alle: "Das geht nicht,
das ist ein Fehler der Mitarbeiter."
Wir fragten uns weniger: "Woher
hatte die CS diese Informationen?"
"Was hat sie unternommen,
um die Leute zu ertappen?"
Diese Frage haben wir uns
bis zum Fall Khan nicht gestellt.
Die Antwort wäre vielleicht:
Sie haben eine interne Truppe, plus
Externe, ähnlich wie eine Polizei.
Welche Mittel setzte die CS
vor dem Fall Khan ein, um zu prüfen,
ob Kaderleute
beim Wechsel zur Konkurrenz
Kunden oder Mitarbeiter mitnehmen?
Die Credit Suisse schreibt uns:
Erich Wunderli
ist seit 40 Jahren Privatdetektiv
und bildet angehende Beschatter aus.
Privatdetektiv
sei kein geschützter Titel,
es gebe viele unseriöse Anbieter.
Die Frage,
wieso Khans Beschattung aufflog,
ist derzeit das grosse Thema
in seiner Branche.
Ich kann mich erinnern,
dass ich gerade im Cafe sass.
Wir lesen jeweils die Zeitung
und kommentieren sie.
Dann sagte mir jemand:
"Hast du gelesen bei der CS?"
"Detektive - waren das deine?"
"Was, wo?"
Dann las ich es auch
und musste sagen:
"Nein! Aber hallo?
Das geht ja gar nicht."
Drei sind ausgestiegen
und einer wollte dem anderen
das Handy wegnehmen?
Nein, das ist dilettantisch.
Waren das wirklich Detektive?
Das kann ich mir nicht vorstellen.
Eine Arbeitsweise,
die bei uns nicht vorkommt.
Das gibt es einfach nicht,
das darf man nicht.
Wir sagen unseren Schülern immer:
"So nicht."
Das wäre
ein gutes Negativbeispiel gewesen.
Es war die Firma investigo GmbH
aus Otelfingen, die Khan observierte.
Sie nimmt schriftlich Stellung.
Oh, scheisse.
Jetzt fällt der schon wieder runter.
Nein!
Immer fallen mir
die Fünffrankenstücke runter.
Und schon ist er dran.
- Der Tracker ist gesetzt.
Wie lange würde der halten?
- 14 Tage.
Und ...
Den kann man jetzt
mit einer App orten.
Hier ist jetzt Tracker 4 befestigt.
Sobald das Auto losfahren würde,
könnte man es verfolgen -
in der ganzen Schweiz
oder sogar im Ausland.
Sind Sie noch nie aufgeflogen?
Wir sind noch nie aufgeflogen.
Einmal ist es mir
in Oerlikon aber passiert,
als ich eine Frau observierte,
dass ich ihr etwas zu nahe kam.
Sie schaute mich
schon zum zweiten Mal an
und ich dachte: "Jetzt wird es
heiss, ich muss aufpassen."
Ich dachte, ich nehme ihr den Wind
aus den Segeln, und tippte sie an:
"Entschuldigung,
darf ich Sie etwas fragen?"
Und sie:
"Was wollen Sie von mir?"
"Verfolgen Sie mich?"
Das haben Sie gesagt?
- Ja, das fragte ich sie.
Sie sagte dann: "Genau dasselbe
dachte ich von Ihnen!"
Und ich:
"Nein, ich bin Ihnen nachgelaufen,
weil ich Sie fragen wollte,
ob Sie mich verfolgen."
"Überall, wo ich bin,
sind Sie auch."
Sie: "Ich habe
genau das Gleiche gedacht."
Wir lachten darüber,
alles war wieder gut
und ich ging weg und bedankte mich.
Dann folgte ihr
die nächste Detektivin unauffällig.
Wieso flog
die investigo-Beschattung auf?
Dazu schreibt die Firma:
Anders gesagt: Khan könnte gewusst
haben, dass er observiert wird,
und dadurch
besonders achtsam gewesen sein.
Nachdem die Beschattung
aufgeflogen war,
spielte die Credit Suisse
den Medien diverse Informationen
zur investigo GmbH zu.
Die Firma teilt mit:
Die Credit Suisse
will sich dazu nicht äussern.
Es war ein Sicherheitsexperte
aus Kloten, der den Kontakt
zwischen investigo und
der Credit Suisse vermittelt hatte.
Auch sein Name wurde bekannt.
Kurz darauf nahm er sich das Leben.
There was
quite a lot of news this morning.
We just need to keep an eye
on the market reaction.
(Mann) In Switzerland, a lot of
media reporting and public opinion
is pretty negative towards ...
Der Überwachungsskandal
macht international Schlagzeilen.
Eine der zentralen Fragen:
Wusste Tidjane Thiam,
der CEO der Credit Suisse,
über die Observation Bescheid?
Wir haben keinerlei Beweise,
dass er darüber informiert war.
Die "Financial Times" in London,
das wirtschaftsliberale Leibblatt
der Teppichetagen,
ging alsbald
auf schmerzliche Distanz.
Für den Bankenexperten der
"Financial Times" war sofort klar:
Der Stuhl des CEO wackelt gewaltig.
Eine der wichtigsten Fragen
bei diesem Skandal
war für uns:
Kann der CEO der Credit Suisse,
Tidjane Thiam, weitermachen
angesichts des Schadens
für seine persönliche Reputation
und für den Namen seiner Bank?
Konzernchef Tidjane Thiam bleibt,
gehen muss seine rechte Hand, der
operative Chef Pierre-Olivier Bouee.
Der Franzose ist ein
langjähriger Wegbegleiter Thiams,
und so heisst es offiziell,
dass Bouee allein
den Auftrag gegeben habe,
den früheren Chef der internationa-
len Vermögensverwaltung, Iqbal Khan,
nach seinem Abgang zur UBS
zu beschatten.
Nein, das ist
überhaupt nicht glaubwürdig.
Man muss sich fragen,
was sein engster Vertrauter
in der Geschäftsleitung
alles ohne sein Wissen tat.
Wenn sein engster Vertrauter, mit
dem er seit 20 Jahren unterwegs ist,
ihm in einer sehr heiklen Sache
keinen reinen Wein einschenkt
und ihn darüber im Dunkeln lässt
und er nicht sofort durchstartet
wegen dieser totalen Illoyalität
oder dieses totalen Versagens
eines engen Mitarbeiters,
dann hat er seinen Laden
nicht im Griff.
Es musste jemand gehen,
der die Verantwortung übernimmt.
Das ist das Wichtigste.
Aber dass man nur
zwei Bauernopfer bringt und sagt,
man habe nichts gewusst ...
Als Führung muss man auch die
Verantwortung für Dinge übernehmen,
an denen man keine Schuld hat -
das ist der Witz des Chef-Seins.
Einmal mehr machen Schweizer Banken
Negativschlagzeilen.
In regelmässigen Abständen
rückt der Finanzplatz
die Schweiz in ein schlechtes Licht.
Das Ganze ist sicher nicht gut
für den Bankenplatz in der Schweiz.
Es kommt mir sehr obskur vor.
Viel Testosteron, viel Eitelkeit.
Viel Machtgier.
Darf ich Sie etwas fragen
über die Credit Suisse für SRF?
Kein Interesse.
Wir sind vom Schweizer Fernsehen.
- Ah, nein.
Ich habe keine Zeit, sorry.
Haben Sie Kinder?
- Nein.
Würden Sie sie
in eine Banklehre schicken?
Eine Banklehre? Nein.
In dieser Form
hat sie keine Zukunft mehr.
Wirtschaftshistoriker
Tobias Straumann
beobachtet
eine zunehmende Entfremdung
zwischen internationalen Wirtschafts-
kapitänen und der Zivilgesellschaft.
Das macht ihm Sorgen.
Was die Schweizer Öffentlichkeit
sagt, ist für sie unerheblich.
Das ist das Hauptproblem.
Man beobachtet zunehmend -
seit etwa 20-30 Jahren -
dass sich die Wirtschaftselite,
nicht nur bei den Banken,
sondern bei allen internationalen
Unternehmen in der Schweiz,
vom normalen Leben losgekoppelt hat,
auch vom normalen Wirtschaftsleben.
Das sind getrennte Welten.
Das ist ein Problem - es ist ein
Problem, wenn die Wirtschaftselite
sich von der politischen
Öffentlichkeit abkoppelt.
Das wird schwierig, denn es wird
sicher wieder einen Punkt geben,
an dem die Wirtschaft
Unterstützung braucht -
und dann
wird sie sie nicht bekommen.
Das wird nicht nur
für die Wirtschaft ein Problem sein,
sondern auch
für den Werkplatz Schweiz z.B.
Die Wurzeln der Credit Suisse
reichen zurück bis ins Jahr 1856.
Damals entstand
die Schweizerische Kreditanstalt -
mitgegründet vom grossen Politiker,
Wirtschaftsführer und
Eisenbahnunternehmer Alfred Escher.
Grüss Gott.
- Ich möchte gerne zu meinem Fach.
Sehr gerne.
Wenn Sie so freundlich sind.
Die Schweiz
war lange stolz auf ihre Grossbanken.
Und auf das Bankgeheimnis.
Der Finanzplatz galt als verschwiegen
und zuverlässig.
Zürichs Banker
waren angesehene Persönlichkeiten:
eine Elite
mit nationaler Ausstrahlung.
Man kannte sich vom Militär,
war in Service-Clubs organisiert,
stand der FDP nahe
und las die "NZZ".
Dann kam die Finanzkrise:
eine historische Zäsur,
die die ganze Welt erschütterte.
Spätestens als die Banker von Lehman
Brothers 2008 ihre Büros räumten,
war klar:
Das Finanzsystem stand am Abgrund.
Und weil in dieser Branche inzwischen
alles mit allem zusammenhing,
erreichte die Krise schon bald
auch den Schweizer Finanzplatz.
Der Begriff Banker verkam
quasi über Nacht zum Schimpfwort.
Eine neue Zeitrechnung hat begonnen.
Unsere Volkswirtschaft -
jetzt reicht's!
Keine öffentlichen Gelder mehr!
Die Wut entlud sich v.a.
an der UBS und ihren Exponenten,
die hemmungslos abkassiert hatten
und jetzt vom Staat
gerettet werden mussten.
Diese ganze Kultur,
die vorher geherrscht hatte:
"Wir verdienen zwar viel,
aber wir sind auch wichtig für euch
und wir können das",
diese Kultur brach zusammen.
Und es ist überraschend,
dass sich diese Kultur
überhaupt nicht verändert hat.
Man sieht es bei den Löhnen -
die Löhne sanken vorübergehend.
Sie waren nicht mehr so hoch
wie vor 2008.
Heute sind sie wieder
auf einem ähnlichen Niveau,
zweistellige Millionenbeträge.
Niemand versteht es
und niemand kann es erklären.
Brady Dougan,
ab 2007 CEO der Credit Suisse,
war quasi
die Verkörperung des Exzesses.
2009 bezog er ein Gehalt von 20 Mio.
plus einen Bonus von 70 Mio.
Mit einer Gesamtentlöhnung
von 90 Mio. Fr.
war Dougan
der bestbezahlte Bankmanager Europas.
Nach Brady Dougan, der den aal-
glatten Banker perfekt verkörpert,
übernimmt jetzt
eine schillernde Persönlichkeit
mit Charme und Emotionen.
Wie Sie sehen,
meine geschätzten Damen und Herren,
mein Deutsch
ist etwas rostig geworden.
Sie würden es wohl kaum glauben,
aber im Alter von 18 Jahren
war mein Deutsch besser
als mein Englisch.
2015 wurde Tidjane Thiam,
geboren in der Elfenbeinküste,
CEO der Credit Suisse.
Dougans Nachfolger kam
von einer englischen Versicherung
und sollte die Credit Suisse
strategisch neu ausrichten:
weg vom risikoreichen
Investmentbanking.
Hohe Ambitionen
habe er schon als Schüler gehabt,
erzählte Thiam 2013 in London.
Der Schulvorsteher fragte mich:
"Was willst du tun?"
Und ich sagte: "Ich will an die
Ecole politechnique in Paris."
Er lachte sich kaputt und sagte:
"Weisst du eigentlich,
was das für eine Schule ist?"
"Napoleon hat sie gegründet."
Ich sagte:
"Genau darum will ich da hin."
Der Wechsel von Dougan zu Thiam
sollte auch
ein imagemässiger Neuanfang sein:
endlich raus
aus den Negativschlagzeilen.
Thiam ist vom Typ her jemand,
der banal gesagt
keinen Widerstand duldet.
Er ist der Chef,
und man muss ihm absolute Loyalität
garantieren, sonst wird er giftig.
Er hat die richtigen Entscheidungen
getroffen.
Er hat z.B.
das risikoreiche Investmentbanking
und dessen Geschäfte mit Finanz-
instrumenten massiv zurückgefahren.
Er fokussierte die Bank
neu auf die Vermögensverwaltung.
Darum haben ihn die Shareholder
in diesem Skandal
vermutlich nicht fallen lassen:
Die finden,
er mache einen guten Job.
Herr Thiam ist sicher jemand,
der sagt:
"Ich bin der Sonnenkönig,
ich bin der Chef."
"Ich sage, wer in die Presse kommt
und wer nicht."
"Und als Erster komme ich."
Und dann kam Iqbal Khan.
The next generation
is sometimes portrayed
as a privileged group of people
who are lacking ambition.
Based on my own experience
this is far from the truth.
Khan ist Schweizer
mit pakistanischen Wurzeln.
Im Herbst 2015 wird er von Thiam
mit erst 39 Jahren
zum Chef der internationalen
Vermögensverwaltung erhoben.
Er gilt als aufsteigender Stern.
Unverkrampft.
Jugendlich.
Frisch.
Es heisst, er sei
ein unglaublich guter Motivator.
Er lasse die Leute aber auch machen,
er sei kein Micromanager,
der jedes Detail
im Voraus wissen möchte.
Sondern er lässt sie
an der langen Leine.
Auf der Bühne fast ein Rockstar.
Hier wuchs der spätere Rockstar auf:
in einem Wohnblock in Dübendorf.
Khan machte bei Rene Fitzi
eine KV-Lehre
und liess sich
zum Treuhänder ausbilden.
Später wurde er
Wirtschaftsprüfer und Finanzanalyst.
Also ...
In diesem Büro,
an diesem Arbeitsplatz
hat er seine Lehre gemacht.
Er kam zu mir
und zeigte mir seine Zeugnisse.
Sie waren sehr durchschnittlich.
Keine absoluten Spitzennoten.
Aufgrund seiner Zeugnisnoten
hat er sich
überhaupt nicht aufgedrängt.
Solche wie ihn gab es viele.
Ich fragte ihn,
ob er sich
schon anderswo beworben hätte
und wie er auf uns gekommen sei.
Er sagte, er hätte
sehr viele Absagen bekommen.
Das verstand ich nicht,
denn nach dem Interview
musste man diesen jungen Mann
einfach sofort nehmen.
Er war sehr lernbegierig.
Er wollte immer sofort mehr wissen
als nur die paar Instruktionen,
was er zu tun hatte.
Er fragte immer nach den
Hintergründen, wollte mehr wissen.
Was ihn absolut hervorhob, was
ihn von allen anderen unterschied,
waren unerhört gute Umgangsformen.
Thiam fördert Khan,
die beiden verstehen sich.
Bald schon
wohnen sie sogar nebeneinander,
in Herrliberg
an der Zürcher Goldküste.
Er sagte mir,
das sei ganz zufällig so gekommen.
Diese Liegenschaft ...
Das war eine ältere Liegenschaft.
Er erwarb sie,
riss alles ab und baute etwas Neues.
Er wusste nicht,
dass Thiam sein Nachbar war.
Das hat sich erst
während der Bauzeit herausgestellt,
als sie sich mal getroffen haben.
Aber das geschah nicht bewusst.
Was dann folgt,
ist bester Boulevard-Stoff:
Die beiden Nachbarn geraten sich
offenbar zusehends in die Haare.
An einer Cocktailparty in Thiams Haus
Anfang 2019
soll der Streit dann eskaliert sein.
Es artet aus, alle haben getrunken,
die ganze Geschäftsleitung ist dort,
die Frauen
liegen sich in den Haaren,
vielleicht auch wegen
eines Nachbarschaftsstreits.
Frau Khan hat wohl ein Trampolin
für die Kinder auf der Wiese,
Frau Thiam
bzw. Herr Thiams Partnerin
will vielleicht eher
in der Sonne liegen und Ruhe haben.
So ist das ausgeartet
wie bei Reihenhäusern
in einem Vorort von Liverpool,
könnte man meinen.
Sie fetzen sich vor der versammelten
Geschäftsleitung der Credit Suisse.
Ego, Alphatiere, ein Untergebener,
der seinem Chef die Meinung geigt,
und dieser schlägt zurück.
Nicht physisch, aber so bedrohlich,
dass Herr Khan
es ernst genommen hat.
Ich nehme an, damals
ist das Tuch endgültig zerrissen.
Auch geschäftlich sollen sich
die beiden entfremdet haben.
Khan habe unbedingt
auf Thiams Stuhl gewollt, heisst es.
Ich bin überzeugt,
dass er die Absicht hatte,
Thiams Nachfolger zu werden.
Darauf hatte er hingearbeitet.
Und er hätte es auch gekonnt,
das ist ganz klar.
Aber es kommt anders:
Khan verlässt die Credit Suisse.
Er wechselt zur UBS,
dem schärfsten Konkurrenten -
und das nach einer Übergangsfrist
von gerade mal drei Monaten.
Insider reiben sich die Augen.
Denn das ist neu
am Zürcher Paradeplatz.
Das ist ungewöhnlich.
Normalerweise müssen solche Leute
mindestens neun Monate
bis ein Jahr warten,
bis sie zum direkten Konkurrenten
auf dem gleichen Finanzplatz
wechseln können.
Sie spielen den ganz Tag solche
Machtspiele, solche Pokerspiele,
bei denen es einfach darum geht:
Wer weiss was vom anderen?
Wann kann man das
für sich selbst nutzen?
Das ist ein solches Beispiel.
Herr Khan könnte einiges
über Herrn Thiam wissen - egal was.
Es wird spekuliert, es schwirren
immer Geschichten herum.
Bis jetzt konnte niemand
etwas Richtiges bringen.
Wir sind beim Villenstreit
in Herrliberg stehen geblieben.
Wir alle denken,
es muss doch noch um mehr gehen.
Ich glaube auch, dass es um mehr
geht, aber wir wissen es nicht.
Aber die Tatsache, dass er
so einen guten Vertrag bekommen hat,
deutet darauf, dass Herr Khan etwas
gegen Herrn Thiam in der Hand hatte
und damit Druck erzeugen konnte.
Nicht die feine Art,
aber so läuft es wahrscheinlich.
Und das hat ihm
diesen guten Sprung ermöglicht.
Diese Geschichte
ist wohl noch nicht zu Ende erzählt.